what's going on guys this is Rob and I
will be at San Diego comic-con this year
along with Mariah so if you guys want to
meet up at 12 p.m. on July 21st we will
be at the entrance to the San Diego
Convention Center in front of Harbor
Drive and Fifth Avenue so hopefully
we'll see you there
okay so in this video on to powerful for
Marvel movies I actually want to wrap
back around to the first video we ever
made here on my youtube channel and I
want to talk about jason wyngarde now
here's the thing for those of you guys
who saw spider-man far from home
hey it's Gordon the editor a spoiler
warning for far from home so if you
don't want to hear that skip to this
timecode alright have a good day
imagine everything that happened with
Mysterio when he inspired a man had
their first like battle with each other
but imagine that spider-man couldn't
escape it and that's jason wyngarde
jason wyngarde was a ridiculously
powerful character now admittedly
spider-man does have a spider sense but
here's the kicker about that is I would
argue and this is probably a discussion
I should have with Sal overcometh copses
he's like this spider-man authority but
spider-man's spider-sense only really
ever seems to work if his mine if his
like mind and body are aware that
something's not right but when it comes
to jason wyngarde
he manipulates the five senses right so
he can make you believe that anything
that you're seeing touching tasting
smelling and hearing that is absolutely
real if your mind and body don't know
that things aren't the way they're
supposed to be there'd be no reason for
you to to believe otherwise right so I
imagine jason wyngarde could probably
get the upper hand on spider-man I don't
know if he ever has I love the two of
them I've ever fought I think it'd be a
cool battle and it'd be a cool question
to answer but when it comes to his
character he's kind of nuts but the
funny thing is that he's usually wildly
underused by Marvel when jason wyngarde
first popped up he was originally part
of the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants with
magneto right and he was just an older
man who wore like this you know British
looking cloak thing like an overcoat and
he could manipulate the senses and that
was it but when it was Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby storytelling back then it was
pretty simple it wasn't really nearly as
complex as like Chris Claremont or the
stories that would come decades later
right I mean Stan Lee always kept things
fairly light-hearted but then you get
around to like the Dark Phoenix saga
right like the finish of the Dark
Phoenix saga is when there is a device
created by Emma Frost that amplifies the
powers of jason wyngarde and he's able
to control the Phoenix so because of
that like it gets wild when it comes to
his powers but that's why I say like for
me I think he's probably one of the most
dangerous people to have in the MCU
because imagine for example that like
something happens to the Avengers right
I don't I don't know what it is like
imagine the New Avengers movie pops off
and Marvel introduces the Hellfire Club
before they introduce the x-men which it
kind of makes sense to be honest but the
Hellfire Club is this this organization
that really kind of spans the globe
right and the idea is to occur to it
really to acquire as much power and
influence the world as Ben
they can now within the Hellfire Club
you have what's called the inner circle
so that's where you find Emma Frost and
Sebastian Shaw and Donald Pierce and
jason wyngarde but the inner circle
named themselves after chess pieces
right like black queen white queen black
rook white rook black King white King so
on and so forth and so with that being
the case if they introduce the Hellfire
Club and they say okay so this is an
organization that's trying to you know
attain power and it really seems to be
an oculus right like it's just something
that happens somewhere like there's some
tanker that's taken taken over by some
rogue group you know like we saw in
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
the New Avengers respond and jason
wyngarde happens to be there then while
the New Avengers are going through and
doing their mission then suddenly the
entire tanker just changes right like
this this the belly of this tanker all
these pipes and things you know and
these soldiers running at them and so on
and so forth suddenly it all changes and
they're they're on this white sandy
beach out in the middle of nowhere or
they're in Paris and like there's music
playing children laughing and people are
talking in French and people are talking
in English and there's American tourists
and they're taking pictures you know and
they can feel the wind on their face
they can reach down and touch the ground
and it feels like the ground in Paris
like all this becomes absolute how can
you defeat a foe when you don't know one
where they are and to where you are
right I mean how do you because here's
the thing like it could be one of those
things or like literally like the
Avengers call and they're like okay hey
some what like like shield come in or
like somebody come and get us or
everything like nobody answers and they
have no idea where they are
they could be wandering aimlessly for
the rest of their lives for all you know
for a powerful on the ark that alike
presumably for eternity they could just
Wonder and Wonder and Wonder all
throughout this entire place until their
physical bodies give out all the while
while they're experiencing all that
right like being in Paris and like
tasting the food while they're
experiencing all of that their bodies
are basically just sitting in a Cell in
the brig of a tanker that's how jason
wyngarde works that's how his power
works it's crazy but it's just a
manipulation of the five senses now if
you take that entire concept and you
capitalize on it by saying that those
individuals who are at the mercy of
masterminds illusions are left to
believe that like even though they know
it's an illusion still have a hard time
penetrating it ah then he becomes even
more powerful right because in x-men
number five really like the the second
issue when he popped up because I want
to say was for when we got the
Brotherhood and it was five when they
all fought each other that mastermind
actually created like an illusion of
this brick wall and when he did like the
x-men knew it was an illusion but they
still couldn't pass through it right
because their mind was telling him
that's absolutely real it takes somebody
of like prodigious skill in order to get
past it but that's one of the things
that makes him so dangerous that's what
makes him so capable is because going
back to our example with the Avengers
even if they were walking through Paris
and even if they knew it was an illusion
they wouldn't know how to escape it's
something that kids like you know steal
a jet somewhere and then just fly really
really far and then somehow reach the
barrier of this illusion and pass it the
illusion would just go on forever and
ever and ever right and maybe would just
keep going and going and going the
difference here in really the the
weakness of Master Mind starts to come
into play when he starts to lose his
concentration right because he has to
actually and actively focus on them now
there are ways to get around that if
we're talking about a scenario where
like masterminds on the tanker and like
he's manipulating the Avengers tricking
them into thinking that what they're
seeing is real they're just kind of
running around this tanker where they're
sitting down in the brig or whatever the
case is
if flight backup arrives right like the
x-men showed up or something like that
and they attacked the tanker and then
mastermind losses concentration even if
it only flickers for a moment it would
give the Avengers the out they need and
a way to escape the illusion and then
get back into the real world right to
actually actively engage in a battle
with with mastermind and so on in the
real world but there are ways around
that right so not even using the mind
tap device that was created by Emma
Frost that allowed him to tap into and
control the Phoenix if we look past and
we say okay let's skip forward to like
2006 with civil war and let's use like
MGH right like you to growth hormone
this is a drug that basically amplifies
the powers of any mutant that comes
across their eye that uses it that's how
it is that nitro managed to blow up
Stamford Connecticut is because he was
on MGH right so like when he detonated
instead of creating like a smaller
explosion like he normally did he blew
up an entire section of Stamford
Connecticut like wipe the city off the
map and that led the like deaths of tons
of people and so with that being the
case you turn around you say okay like
masterminds powers on their base level
are able to like manipulate a whole city
then you feed him MGH the powers become
more potent and to become more
widespread which means now he becomes a
global threat and everything that
everybody's seen is an absolute truth
but you have this guy who amplifies his
powers and he's just like on this tanker
somewhere and everyone in the world
believes that like the Avengers are bad
guys right like everybody would believe
that like Thanos came back
Captain America Falcon is Stannis and
everybody else is like the black order
right and so it's just like okay so like
we have to take them out so now the
x-men and and like the Fantastic Four's
to me that they're there and all the
superheroes just start like fighting
against the Avengers right so like that
starts to elevate mastermind to becoming
like a huge threat in the MCU and that's
why I say like the guy can go either way
if you if you do in the right way and if
you give the right kind of
substance to amplify his powers suddenly
like he's a he's a threat for like
multi-legged like a like a Thanos level
threat not so much in terms of like the
full totality of the power he possesses
like blinking out half the life in the
universe but in terms of the threat he
poses to like the super heroes on earth
like he becomes a big-time movie villain
this is the kind of character we're
talking about and this is why I say like
mastermind has been painfully underused
by Marvel over the years right I mean
he's ahe's a wildly powerful guy he's
usually used as like a plot device or
just like a character who's there or
like a henchman or something along those
lines but if somebody wrote him
effectively and somebody gave him his
due the guy could could unleash hell on
the entirety of earth and Marvel the
only people who could really get around
that the only who could really really
escape that even if he used MGH would be
like high-level reality war purse rights
like Franklin Richards or or somebody
like like the molecule man Owen Reese or
possibly Doctor Doom depending on how
advanced his magic is based on the story
that's being told a super high-level
telepath so like probably Jean Grey as
the Phoenix issues around assuming that
she has like the full totality of the
Phoenix's powers so she's like white
Phoenix of the crown Charles Xavier to
pan on how is depending on how his
stories being told Emma Frost again
depending on how her stories being told
because their powers fluctuate right
like how powerful they are as telepaths
Emma Frost and Xavier anyway it
fluctuates based on the story right like
Xavier was like more powerful than Emma
Frost for a long time and then you get
to the events of Civil War and then Emma
Frost is like no no I'm way more
powerful than Xavier is right so I mean
it gets it gets kind of crazy in terms
of how their powers fluctuate and how
they change and how they how they alter
depending on on what stories being told
um that also kind of begs the question
would masterminds powers work on
Wolverine because as far as I'm aware
they're there I mean it's it's worked
like a small portion but not to a huge
degree right because if you go and you
read the Dark Phoenix saga when
mastermind uses his powers unlike all
the other x-men and Jean Grey
by that point Wolverine had been like
knocked underground right like he had
been like knocked to the ground by by
what's his name the guy they can
basically manipulate gravity increase
people's weight essentially and in turn
like Wolverine wasn't really subjected
to the whole thing that everybody else
was under the effect of mastermind so
there's always been one of those things
we're all wearing kind of escaped or mom
will try to sort of dodge the question I
don't believe the two of them have ever
fought but again like I could be wrong
here so it creates an interesting
scenario somebody with like a healing
factor or the ability to of the two to
kind of avoid illusion so somebody like
well not really the Incredible Hulk is
he was manipulated by Scarlet Witch in
the MCU I'm Wolverine again it's kind of
a finicky situation somebody like
Deadpool it wouldn't affect him because
he like break stuff
fourth wall so he's like no no let me
show you my reality and it's like
there's people watching us right now and
then like mastermind goes crazy and has
like a total meltdown and dies I mean I
have no idea but but again he's a super
powerful character he's he's wildly
capable I would say he's a threat cable
II a worthy of like an Avengers film in
and of itself right like a team-up film
between like the Avengers Fantastic Four
in the x-men
I think he's worthy of that just because
of the level of power he has it was
pushed to the limits and if he's given
the right way to amplify them but look
at being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain and make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the robb for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
you
you